the former secretary of state for the
united states of america
mike pompeo is joining us today and mr
secretary we played that music because
you're coming home you're now
part of the family welcome aboard
welcome to the family
uh it is great to be with you steve i
think we needed another kansas voice on
fox
so talking i'm thrilled to be part of
i'm i'm thrilled to be part of the team
thank you very much sir good to have you
all right it's the first topic
on we got this late last night the new
york times reporting i think first
that there was uh some type of sabotage
at a nuclear facility in iran
uh that would set them back about a year
as they started to weaponize their
uranium which they're not supposed to be
doing
um what is your take on the fact that
the israelis have not denied that
they're behind this
well brian look any nation that feels
threatened it's very existence as the
israelis surely must now that this
administration is
headed to climb back in the terrible
nuclear deal with the iranians
is going to do what it takes to defend
itself i don't know for sure what
happened there in israel
but i can assure you of this the
countries in the region not just the
israelis but all the countries in the
region
know that the trump administration the
united states was with them
we were prepared to fight back against
the world's largest state sponsor of
terry in iran
this administration appears to be in
vienna appeasing them
and so it doesn't surprise me that
countries are taking action to make sure
that the iran never gets a nuclear
weapon
so the secretary of defense lloyd austin
is in jerusalem
with netanyahu and has declared an
iron-clad commitment to israel
yet the biden administration is talking
about possibly reviving the iran nuclear
deal
what do you say well those two ideas are
are hard to square ainsley
now i'm happy that he talked about an
ironclad relationship with israel that's
great news
it's important it's right for israel
it's right for the middle east most
importantly it'll secure american
freedom
as well but it's not words it's deeds
that people in that region watch and
when
you have rob malley and wendy sherman
running an appeasement campaign in
vienna
when you see them lifting terror
sanctions or at least saying that
they're prepared to consider lifting
terror sanctions
on a regime that has terrorized the
region puts american lives at risk
that's not good for our country it's not
good for our
friends in israel and it doesn't feel
very ironclad
when you're about to go back into a deal
many of which provisions
have already expired sure mr secretary
as soon as joe biden came into office he
signed a bunch of executive orders
one of them undid so many of the things
uh at our southern border and
it is now a disaster down there although
i think they
are calling it just a challenging
circumstance
how does it make you feel as somebody
who worked with the last administration
for
years to try to get us to advance to a
certain point
to see the incoming administration just
undo
so much of what you did
you know steve it it always uh
i always find it interesting when they
talk about the fact that we did america
alone when in fact
the deal that we struck to secure our
southern border was something we worked
hard with the
mexican government we worked hard with
the government in guatemala and el
salvador and honduras we had real
relationships with those people we
negotiated we got to uh
we got to a place that made life better
for their people and secured our
southern border into
to have watched them come in and just
flip the switch and the tragedy that we
now see of these lives that
these people are trying to come through
mexico to get into the united states
because
president biden greenlighted this it's
absolutely tragic and to
to watch them do this in a unilateral
way and make the lives worse for not
only people
to live in texas in arizona and
california but people all across
our southern boundary it's just tragic
the woman in charge of the border just
resigned she's leaving in april oops
what a terrible job she did and now we
send in they sent an
envoy down to me with the el salvador
president he said no you wouldn't see me
so i'm not going to see you
in mexico they say forget the remaining
mexico policy you blew that up we're not
going back to it
uh can you believe how these these
relationships have fractured so quickly
they're not even there 100 days
you know but it took a lot of work this
was hard work building those
relationships is what good diplomacy
does that's what our team did
we we watched these countries say fine
we'll help you with your problem at the
southern border but we've got to get
this
right and you have to you america have
to do the right things too we did that
we negotiated we made clear
we were going to close the border people
weren't going to be permitted to come
here
illegally and when we did that we we
turned off the
magnet we the incentives for people to
make that terrible trek across mexico
were gone
and then we began to work with these
countries to make sure that we handled
it well
you can't just you can't just flip the
switch on countries around the world you
have to work alongside of them and build
partnerships that's how we protect
american sovereignty
mr secretary thank you for joining us
welcome again to fox we're glad to have
you
thank you all you're welcome thank you